[Música]
y en directo a América llegó el momento
de hablar de economía por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge qué tal Muy buenas noches Andrés
Jorge la mitad de la inversión de tesla
en México impactaría el resto de
empresas mexicanas cómo es eso bueno
Hasta ahora se sabe que la inversión
rondaría entre los 5.000 y los Diez mil
millones de dólares y así lo Afirma el
director de análisis y estrategia
bursátil del banco Santander según él si
se calcula la inversión en 5000 millones
de dólares la mitad será contenido
nacional 2500 millones de dólares según
su análisis las grandes empresas del
país obtendrían beneficios equivalentes
acerca del 80% de la inversión de elon
mus en La Norteña ciudad de Monterrey
mientras que un 20% quedaría en las
pymes según alas Alan Alanís que es este
estratega del banco dijo que la
inversión realizada por Moss oscilaría
entre el 4% y el 8% del producto interno
bruto nacional mexicano ahí el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
confirmó que tesla se insta El norteño
Estado de Nuevo León donde construirá su
primera planta Automotriz en América
Latina la planta convertirá a México en
un centro de fabricación de vehículos
eléctricos incluso cuando Estados Unidos
intenta reforzar la fabricación nacional
con la ley de reducción de la inflación
de la administración de Joe biden México
durante años ha avanzado su producción
en el suministro de los fabricantes de
vehículos de gasolina y se le ofrece
ventajas como una mano de obra
relativamente barata y acuerdos de libre
comercio con 50 países por ejemplo
Estados Unidos solamente tiene acuerdos
similares con 20 países Jorge Vamos
hasta Argentina al presidente Alberto
Fernández inauguró el periodo
legislativo con un discurso que dijo
sobre el fmi el déficit fiscal la deuda
empezó y las reservas bueno Fernández
defendió su gestión económica y aseguró
que es uno de los países que más ha
crecido en la región en los últimos dos
años Aunque según él la alta inflación
es un factor de Central de
desorganización de la economía durante
la intervención Fernández se felicitó la
labor del ministro de economía Sergio
massa e hizo una crítica indirecta al
fondo monetario internacional con el que
precisamente tiene un acuerdo para
refinanciar un préstamo de 44 mil
millones de dólares firmado en 2018 que
usemos parte de la declaratoria
seguramente cometidos los errores pero
tengo la íntima convicción de que
sumamos muchísimos aciertos en este
tiempo escuché como una y otra vez
criticaban mi moderación
pero con mi moderación fui capaz de
enfrentar a los acreedores privados y
pude ponerle freno a los
condicionamientos que el fondo monetario
internacional le había impuesto al
gobierno que me presidió la economía
volvió a crecer durante 2022 y registró
un aumento del cinco coma cuatro por
ciento de este modo sumamos más
crecimiento al 10,3% que se registró
durante el año 2021 somos uno de los
países que más creció en estos dos
últimos años todas las proyecciones
propias y de los organismos
internacionales señalan que en 2023
volveremos a crecer seremos uno de los
países que más haya crecido en el mundo
sin duda una de las cosas que más golpea
la gestión de Fernández Es la inflación
en Argentina que llegó en enero hasta el
98,8%. Jorge y de ahí vamos hasta Israel
como las reforma judicial del gobierno
israelí podría afectar la economía ya
hay señales de esta afectación por
ejemplo el che cayó casi un 6% durante
el último mes y alcanzó su valor más
bajo frente al dólar en más de tres años
el índice de referencia ta 125 de la
bolsa de tel aviv retrocedió un 3,5% y
cada vez más empresas trasladan sus
activos fuera del país con una fuga de
capitales que se estima ya en 4.000
millones de euros en Israel con buenos
índices de crecimiento desde hace 10
años Gracias precisamente a las
políticas económicas de netanyajo la
industria tecnológica representa casi el
15% del producto interno bruto y
concentra más de un tercio de toda la
exportaciones varios economistas
empresarios académicos y referentes de
varias industrias se muestran
preocupados por la reforma y su impacto
en la economía según ellos la reformas
acabaría la justicia debilitaría la
separación de poderes y las bases
democráticas de Israel dando paso a un
sistema con mayor peso del ejecutivo
Jorge Vamos hasta el Líbano las
etiquetas de los precios en los
supermercados están quedando obsoletas
en cuestión de horas porque
principalmente por la volatilidad de la
moneda la la libanesa alcanzó las 90.000
unidades por un dólar en el mercado
negro un nuevo récord A la baja en medio
de esta grave crisis económica que vive
ese país en Perú algunos comercios han
instalado un escáner web que permite a
los consumidores leer el código de
barras de cada artículo y saber si su
precio está en tiempo real algunas
estanterías también quitan los letreros
por la volatilidad y otros deciden poner
el precio en dólares para darnos una
idea a comienzos de diciembre pasado la
libra libanesa se encaminaba alrededor
se cambiaba alrededor de 40 mil unidades
por dólar en el mercado negro tres meses
después más tarde un billete
estadounidense se compra ya a casi
90.000 por esto el ministro libanés de
economía a minsalam anunció que los
supermercados podrían empezar a poner
los precios de sus productos en dólares
al reconocer que algunos estaban
teniendo que cambiar todos los carteles
varias veces al día debido a la
volatilidad de la moneda local Jorge
Hurtado con la información económica
Gracias seguimos con más aquí en directo
América
[Música]